c'est ici dans cet immeuble que dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi dernier on a
évité le pire
pratiquement plein coeur de vesoul un
incendie qui aurait pu avoir des
conséquences dramatiques et c'est un
marginal de 38 ans qui a reconnu les
faits après plusieurs heures de garde à
vue
c'est cette personne qui squattaient cet
immeuble dans la nuit du vendredi au
samedi qui était fortement alcoolisé
puisqu'il reconnaît les faits et qui
s'est endormi avec une cigarette
donc cet envahissement des conséquences
dramatiques puisque cet immeuble
accueillait deux entreprises un cabinet
dentaire est une entreprise qui sont
complètement dévasté aujourd'hui le
préjudice économique et de plusieurs
milliers d'euros il est extrêmement
important
présenté en comparution immédiate en
début d'après midi
l'homme a été condamné à neuf mois de
prison ferme neuf mois de mise à
l'épreuve et devra occuper un logement
de réinsertion pendant trois ans à sa
sortie de prison